- You realize that
this world is becoming
more and more tech focused.
And cities have two options.
They can either
embrace that reality.
Or they can ignore it to their
peril of their residence.
(upbeat music)
- All right, I'm Dave Rubin.
We are on location in Miami.
With Miami mayor Francis Suarez.
Mr. Mayor first off.
The shirt matches the
shoes, matches the socks.
You are living in
the synth wave future
that was promised to us
in the eighties, huh?
- That's right, that's right.
This is Miami for you.
It's Miami style.
Absolutely.
- Definitely Miami style.
I mean, I guess the best
way to start this off.
Is that this place
is just blowing up.
You gotta be kind of feeling
good about life and the world
and what you're doing.
- Yeah.
- Is that the
easiest question ever
been asked to you before?
- It's the most common,
that's for sure.
Yeah, no.
It really is, I think a
generational opportunity.
A generational moment.
Miami was always a great place.
I mean, pre this
sort of tech boom.
We were growing significantly.
We're not a well kept secret.
But I think what
is happening now is
order of magnitudes
is different, right?
You're now creating a kind
of ecosystem and economy.
That's really gonna propel
our city into the future.
The world is changing.
It's changing at a
pace of disruption.
That we've never seen before.
And we're talking about this
a little bit off camera.
Cities just don't
get it, oftentimes.
They don't understand
that things are changing.
And they're changing
permanently.
And they have to adapt quickly.
- When did you get it?
I mean, did you know
about this sort of shift
before you were elected in
2017 or did this just happen?
- So I was actually elected
in 2009 to the council.
As a councilman.
And for about 10 years.
We were trying to create
this technological ecosystem.
I'm a young elected
official for a major city.
I'm 43.
I was 32 at the time.
And I realized that I
was a first generation
with a smartphone.
I was a first-generation
with laptops, cell phones.
And you realize that our
world is more and more
engulfed by technological tools.
I now have a seven-year-old
and a three-year-old.
And my three-year-old just the
other night was telling me,
"Dad, let's take a selfie."
With her, we call it
"Gutete" in Spanish.
With her pacifier.
She's taking a selfie with me.
So three years old.
So you realize-
- Cameras and pacifiers,
it's found it's way.
- It's coming, it's coming.
- Yeah.
- But you realize that
this world is becoming
more and more tech focused.
And cities have two options.
They can either
embrace that reality.
Or they can ignore it to their
peril of their residence.
- Were you worried at
all that the people
were gonna come
from San Francisco
and bring all of the
bad policies and ideas
that basically wrecked
Silicon Valley,
and wrecked San Francisco?
- I hear worry a lot.
I actually don't worry.
And I'll tell you why.
My family unfortunately
was exiled
from a communist
country in Cuba.
And I don't see people
getting on rafts
and trying to go back to Cuba.
You know what I mean?
It's just not, the
people that come here
to Miami are traumatized.
They are traumatized by
governments that don't work.
By policies that don't work.
And frankly, the decision
to leave a particular city
is a very difficult decision.
Particularly when
you have a family.
And to uproot your
family and say,
"I'm going somewhere else."
That is not easy.
And so for me.
I find it very hard to
believe that anybody
is gonna make that very
difficult decision.
Basically trauma-based, right?
To come to a new city.
And then create
the same policies
that created the
conditions for them
to wanna leave in
the first place.
- What kind of chaos has
it caused in the last year
being here?
I mean, real estate
prices are "bananas."
Rents are going crazy.
These are all good
set of problems.
But it must be a lot for
you to just have to manage.
- You know it's interesting.
The real estate
prices are "bananas."
And homes are on the
water, like this home.
You know what I mean?
But we're comparatively
speaking, incredibly affordable.
So for example.
In downtown Miami,
the urban core.
You can get a one bedroom
apartment in an un-subsidized,
like not affordable housing
or anything like that.
Building, brand new, $1,450.
In Manhattan it's $3,700.
In San Francisco, it's $3,700.
So you're talking about a
three to one differential.
That hasn't changed,
from one day to the next.
And then we're building a
ton of affordable housing.
We have the ability to
build supply, which cities.
Like San Francisco, the
Bay Area oftentimes.
And New York can't do it.
Because New York is
sort of overbuilt.
And San Francisco has restricted
their ability to build.
So we have the ability
to remain competitive
for decades into the future.
Which I think is
a huge competitive
advantage for our city.
- So I think when most people
think of conservatives.
They think of some
kind of old white guy
sitting in a smoking room.
And flipping through the
"Wall Street Journal."
Or something like that.
You're a conservative.
It seems to me that
you're sort of what
the future of conservatism is.
What does that
actually mean to you?
What are your kind of
guiding principles?
- I grew up, I was born in 1977.
So I grew up sort
of in the eighties.
- 76.
You're a young buck.
- There you go.
My dad was mayor
in 1985, of Miami.
And I grew up sort of
in the Reagan years.
So for me it's sort of
being a Reagan Republican.
Was someone that was
strong on national defense.
For me, I believe in
having a balanced budget.
Even though that's
something that
our federal government has
not been able to do for long.
- Are you guys balanced here?
- We are.
We actually have a surplus.
We have a $150 million
surplus in the city of Miami.
We have the second highest
bond rating we've ever had.
And the highest we've
ever had in the history
under my leadership.
So it's a double A plus.
So I believe in fiscal
responsibility for governments.
I think governments should
live within their means.
I think that government
should be there
to facilitate not obstruct.
And oftentimes they're
obstructionists.
But as a conservative, I
also, and as a young person.
And someone who sees,
even young conservatives,
and young liberals.
Come up, concerned
about the environment.
So I think that's something that
we have to have a
better conversation on.
Immigration is another issue.
That we're a city of immigrants.
We're a country of immigrants.
That's another
issue that I think
we need to have a
healthier conversation on
than the one that
we're having right now.
In the sort of
national landscape.
- Yeah.
Where does the Bitcoin
stuff fit in this new future
conservative Mecca that
we've got going here?
You just did the big conference.
- Yeah.
We just did the
biggest, the largest
Bitcoin conference in the world.
We also had FTX.
Which is a large, a
crypto trading platform.
Out of Hong Kong.
Name the arena where
the Miami Heat play.
$200 million naming deal.
We had Blockchain.com
headquartered in
the city of Miami.
300 jobs.
And eToro which is-
- Don't forget
Locals.com moved here.
- And Locals.com as well.
And eToro as well.
So I mean, we've had a
ton of crypto companies
moving over here.
And Blockchain and Bitcoin
companies, moving over here.
Because we believe, we
were sort of the "David,"
in this "David and
Goliath" story, right?
But we believe that to be,
sort of to have that
transformational moment.
We had to step outside
of the conventional box.
And I thought that
Bitcoin and crypto
was our way of doing that.
We're the first
city in the world,
sort of the first city
in the United States,
second city in the world to
put the Satoshi's white paper
on our website.
We're the first
city in the world
to begin the process of
allowing our employees
to get paid in Bitcoin.
- Do you get all of it?
Or is it just like you have
good people around you?
Cause some of the tech stuff,
the high-end, high level
tech stuff is a lot.
- No, I get it, I get it.
I get it because, so I
have finance background.
My dad was an engineer,
is an engineer.
My grandfather was
an engineer as well.
So I get the
mathematics behind it.
I get the principle behind it.
I was actually part of the
Florida Blockchain Foundation
when it began.
And I'm actually part of the
Florida Blockchain Task Force.
Named by the CFO of Florida.
To promulgate, state
regulations and laws.
To hopefully to continue
to bring crypto to Miami.
And to Florida.
- Do you have other mayors
in, either in Florida
or in the rest of the country
that are kind of pissed?
That they're kind of jealous.
Like this guy is making
it happen, and we're not.
Either cause we're handicapped
by our own state governments
or whatever it might be.
- The ones that probably would
be pissed, are not calling.
I think they feel, I
can't speak for them.
They may feel like they're,
and they may believe
some of the policies that
their cities are promulgating.
That I think are not
good for their cities.
But I can tell you.
I've gotten a ton of
mayors that call me
from across the country.
And chambers of commerce
from across the country
that call me and say,
"Hey, how do we replicate
what you're doing down there?"
And for us.
They're some things that
are hard to replicate.
Miami is kind of
hard to replicate.
But there are other things
that I think are very basic.
For us, basically our formula
for success is three things.
Keep taxes as low
as humanly possible.
While other cities
defund police.
We're investing in our police.
And we have the highest number
of police officers ever.
So public safety is
incredibly important to us.
It's something that we sell.
Being one of the safest
big cities in America.
And the third thing is we
focus on quality of life.
We know the fundamental
truth that nobody
can live yesterday again.
So the most important
decision that
we all make in our lives.
Is where we are at
this very moment.
Where we're gonna be tomorrow.
Where we're gonna
be the day after.
And if you create
the kind of city
that really respects
that decision.
For example.
We have 555 homeless
in the city of Miami.
We wanna get to functional zero.
Which means we wanna be
one of the first big cities
in America, not to
have any homeless.
- I mean, I've been
here for five days.
I have not seen one
homeless person.
I come from LA.
It's very, very different.
- It's very different.
And I think, we've done
a variety of things
over a number of years
to get to that point.
And we wanna get to zero.
- For example.
What's one thing you've
done on the homeless?
That I can bring back
with me to California.
- We have something
called the Homeless Trust.
We spend about $50
million a year.
It's a food and beverage tax.
Basically a tourist tax it's
not paid for by our residents.
But it generates money.
And we use that money
to build facilities.
To treat the homeless
in a comprehensive way.
They're obviously,
a lot of them have
mental health and
drug addiction issues.
And vocational training.
So that they can leave a shelter
with the ability
to make a living
and reintegrate into society.
So they get mental
health counseling.
They get drug
addiction counseling.
And they also get
vocational training.
- When you see the mayors
of say, LA, San Francisco,
Seattle, Portland.
All the progressive mayors
that are just raising taxes.
And then you see the reverse
of all of the policies
that you've got working here.
Do you ever think maybe I
could just call these guys
and explain basic economics
to them or something?
I just never can
understand the disconnect
between the things
that they say.
And then the results
that end up happening.
- A lot of them are my friends.
And I'm gonna be, if
reelected in November.
Which hopefully will be
a non-event God willing.
- You got elected with 86%.
And I mean, what
are we gonna we do-
- We gotta up man.
I'll tell you a funny
story about that later.
But I think, if re-elected
I'm gonna be the president
Of the US Conference of Mayors.
So one of the cool things is.
My colleagues, those mayors.
Have chosen me to be the
president of all the mayors
in the United States.
And I think it's a really
wonderful opportunity
to take this formula that
has been successful in Miami.
And export it to urban America.
I think there's some things
that we can do on gun violence.
that you can do on homelessness.
And frankly, I'm willing to
talk to anybody, any mayor.
And give them advice.
But sometimes I think it's hard.
Because it's either
what they believe.
Which is sort of
antithetical to what I think
is a growth policy.
Or what the residents believe.
Which oftentimes make it hard.
Because they're
sort of boxed in.
- Right.
Where does DeSantis
fit into all this?
It seems like from again,
for me 3000 miles away.
That's the best governor
in the country right now.
- Yeah.
I think he did some
things that were very
sort of counter
narrative, right.
And open the state
up a lot earlier than
a lot of people thought what
would have been a good idea.
And it turned out to
be great for the city.
And certainly great
for the state.
And he's gotten a
ton of kudos on that.
And I think, I pretty sure
that if he's reelected in 2022,
which I think is also, he's
got a very good shot of that.
2024, I wouldn't be
surprised if he puts
his name in he ring.
- I saw a little
glimmer in the eye.
I think you might
know something there.
Where does that put you then?
- Look, I've, again I
have to get reelected.
And obviously I have
a year and a half
as hopefully president
US Conference of Mayors.
But I've talked about
this in the past.
There's only a few things
that I'd be interested
in doing beyond being mayor.
Which has been an amazing thing.
Being governor of State
of Florida in 2026,
it's something that I
would certainly consider.
- Does it ever seem
odd to you that
you're governor of all things.
Like somebody who gets it.
You get business and
all of those things.
I know there's a
lot of good people.
Usually kind of right-leaning.
Who just don't wanna
go into government.
Because they don't believe
that government is everything.
So then they just don't do it.
And then we get worse
and worse politicians.
- Well, that's part
of the problem.
Government isn't everything.
And shouldn't be everything.
And I think part of the
issue we have in our society.
Is people think that
government needs to solve
all our problems.
It's not the way it works.
Government was
supposed to be created
for a limited amount of reasons.
The things that we're good
at are core competencies.
And then, when you
have good leaders
that lead in government.
They can work with
the private sector.
With the philanthropic sectors
to deal with big problems.
Like homelessness and others.
But I think, there's
this misperception
that you just keep growing
the size of government.
And that it can somehow
solve a bunch of problems.
That government has been
historically unable to do.
- It put band-aids on
problems it's created, right?
- Exactly.
- That's pretty much it.
Or make the problems worse.
- Or make them worse.
What's been sort
of unexpected as
this all has blown up here.
I guess either on good or bad.
Just generally so much at once.
- Yeah.
For me, if you would've told
me on December 3rd, right?
That the next day I was
gonna put out a tweet
that was gonna be, they call it
"the tweet heard
around the world."
- Yeah.
- And how can I help tweet.
In terms of making
Miami Silicon Valley.
And that that was gonna get
2.7 million impressions.
- Honestly, I don't think
I knew of you until then.
And that day suddenly everyone
I knew in the tech world
was like, that's the guy,
that's the city, let's go.
And then it's just been, yeah.
- It's been crazy.
Ever since then.
I mean, I found what
I call in Twitter,
a portal of positivity.
You know what I mean?
And I tweeted 800 more times
in the month of December.
Which got 27 million.
- Generally, that's
not a good thing.
- And this is gonna sound
really "hokey pokey."
What I'm gonna tell you.
But in many ways
I found my voice.
You know what I mean?
It kind of sounds, book clubish.
But I really did.
I was able to really
express myself.
Be myself without the
usual concerns and worries,
"Hey, I'm gonna make a mistake?"
Am I gonna say something wrong?
Usually if you look at elected
officials in social media.
It's very antiseptic.
It's like they went
and then cut a ribbon.
Or they went and they did this.
They don't have a personality.
They can't really
express themselves,
cause they're afraid.
They're afraid of
making a mistake.
Or saying the wrong thing.
And at some point I just
said, you know what.
I'm gonna go all in.
Let's see how this goes.
- Yeah.
- And it's been great.
It's been a lot of fun.
I've, it's part
of what allowed me
to get into the
crypto space as well.
At the level that I did.
Because I was really
getting great feedback.
And I said, I gotta do more.
- Were you kinda shocked?
So you put that tweet out.
And then it was
basically everyone
that I know in the tech world,
was just like, that's it.
You just shocked that they
immediately were like,
what can I do?
And then you basically just
set up meetings with people.
Right?
- I was shocked.
But it was also a tremendous
learning experience, right?
In the sense that I
realized what this world
was all about now.
This world is highly,
highly disruptive.
I mean I gotta say this.
I don't even know what
camera to look into.
- Somewhere over there.
- There, here.
This world is highly,
highly disruptive.
To the point where
the paradigm can shift
on you in a second.
- Yeah.
- And I think that's
what some of these cities
are not completely
understanding.
And I think that as
you see what I call
this confluence of capital
coming from New York,
Silicon Valley, and Miami's
geo position, right?
Close to South America,
and Central America.
Close to the Middle
East, Israel and Europe.
We're sort of in the
middle of all that.
We're the place that can really
be that global mega city.
That can be what I call
the capital of capital.
The place where if you
wanna build a business
or start a business.
You gotta be living in Miami.
- No Taxes?
Does it all sort of boil down
to that at the beginning?
- That's a part of the equation.
But it's not all
of the equation.
I mean, I think for
us it was low taxes.
It's incredible weather.
It's incredible amenities
from a city perspective.
Now the restaurants.
Everything is sort
of coming together.
And I think, and it's gonna
sound again, sort of crazy.
But it's being welcoming, right?
I can't tell you how many
people that have told me
look, I would stay, living
in one of these cities.
I'm still paying a lot of taxes.
I'm not getting the services.
I'm not getting a
return on my investment.
I'm not getting any stuff.
- You're just talking
right through me now.
- But at the top
of everything else.
- Yeah.
- I made a feel like I'm
not a good person, right?
The government officials,
the "F Elon Musk."
The, let's criticize
Mark Zuckerberg for
giving $75 million
to a hospital for them
wanting to name it after him.
Let's push Amazon
out of our city.
I mean, that just
doesn't make any sense.
And well, we've been
doing the opposite.
We're like, okay, keep coming.
And we're creating thousands
of high-paying jobs
in our community.
That are gonna have a
try generational impact.
Try generational impact.
It impacts the person who
has a job and their spouse.
It impacts their children.
And their educational
opportunities.
And it's gonna impact
their children's children.
- How do you make
sure that the people
that are the natives here
in the midst of this,
as some prices rise
and things like that.
Don't get pushed out of
communities that they're in,
and that sort of thing?
- Yeah.
It's a hard challenge.
I was actually doing
an interview recently.
With one of our local papers.
And I said look, it's hard.
Because the first thing is.
People are, sort of
complain that there's
a lot of income
inequality in cities.
Which is true.
It's a problem in urban America.
And then you start
bringing high paying jobs.
And they say, well
you're gonna push out.
So it's like, well
what do you want?
Do you want high-paying jobs?
So how do we deal
with income inequality
if we don't bring
high paying jobs.
And I think that what
ties those two things is.
You gotta create an
educational framework
from young children to
university students,
to young adults who are left
out of the tech ecosystem.
To even the elderly.
To create a framework where
they can be integrated
into this economy.
And so we do it with
child savings accounts.
We teach financial literacy.
Every single child
in kindergarten, in
the city of Miami
gets a child savings
account that we fund.
We do it through
a coding program.
We just raised through the,
How Can I Help Campaign.
$70,000 for a coding
program in the inner city.
For robotics and coding.
We're helping facilitate
a tremendous amount
of philanthropy
to universities.
And even working with
some major universities.
Marquee universities.
To try to get partnerships.
Maybe bridge that reputational
gap that we may have.
We're doing a tremendous
amount of stuff on up-scaling.
Either through
vocational training.
Or through companies
like Wyncode.
That was bought by BrainStation.
And then for the elderly.
We're working with
apps like Papa.
To make sure that it relevant
to them, this tech boom.
- Yeah.
You mentioned the elderly.
I was gonna ask you.
I think a lot of people
think of Florida,
but Miami specifically.
I tweeted a "Golden Girls"
clip at you yesterday.
They're not gonna do the
"Golden Girls" theme song.
That's not gonna be the
official theme song of Miami.
All right.
I'll keep working
on you on that one.
But, that people think
of Florida, it's like,
oh, that's where old
people go to retire.
- That was our reputation.
Our reputation was.
We're a sun and fun place.
Or a retirement place.
And I think, what I
tried to do with the,
"how can I help"
tweet and beyond.
Was, I don't know if you ever
seen a cruise ship's turn?
- Like literally turns.
- Literally when it turns.
When a cruise ship
comes into port.
It comes in this way.
And actually you gotta
turn it to go outward.
It actually takes
forever, right?
Because it's a
huge massive thing.
It's like a city
that you're turning.
I've literally got every
single tugboat in Miami.
And turn, what was the
reputation of Miami.
Which is like a cruise ship
turning in as fast as possible.
So we could create
two new industries
in technology and finance
that are high paying.
And they're gonna propel
us into the future.
And make us a city
of the future.
- All right.
Two more things for you.
And then I'm gonna join
you in just a moment.
We're gonna flip
the script here.
- I love it.
- So first off, yeah.
So first off I'm moving my
company Locals down here.
We're hiring right now.
What can we do to
get word out there?
What kind of resources are there
as companies move down here?
- Well, first of all.
What we're doing right now is,
number one thing we can do.
Which is, I've learned
after 12 years,
this is why these
podcasts are so,
have gotten so much play, right?
Is because we're in the
storytelling business, right?
I'm in the
storytelling business.
I realized this after 12
years of being positive.
I'm now a storyteller.
And the story is the
narrative of what Miami is.
And what Miami is going to be.
And so just this podcast,
and the one that we're gonna do,
on the (mumbles) of TikTok.
Continue to tell that
story to a point where.
People may have doubted
it at the beginning.
This is just gonna
be a COVID thing.
Or this is just gonna
be a, in the summer
everybody will leave.
But when you keep telling the
story over and over again.
You pile on success after
success, after success.
The perception
becomes a reality.
You marry perception
with reality.
So that's really important.
I think one of the things
that we want them to know is.
We're setting up funds.
We have a fund already.
Through the Downtown Development
Authority that gives,
as opposed to kicking
out a company.
Would give companies $50,000
a year for three years.
That located downtown Miami.
We're hopefully creating a
fund called "Venture Miami."
Which will be hopefully
an early stage seed fund.
Which we're gonna have
somewhere between two
and $5 million a year
over the next two years.
To help early stage
companies grow.
Which oftentimes,
they're the ones
that have the hardest time.
With the mom-and-pop.
So we're trying to do
everything we can to accelerate
this ecosystem growth.
- Then my final question for
you is if I make the move.
if I just can't take Cali
anymore, I make the move myself.
Can you hook me up
with a house like this?
- When you make the move.
We will do everything
that we can.
- All right, I'll take it.
- We like to have that
red carpet service.
We call it concierge service.
- Yeah.
That's pretty much the limit
of what a mayor can say.
- Well, I can't
give you the house.
But I can put you
in touch with people
who may wanna sell
you a house like this.
- Mayor Suarez.
Thank you so much.
- Awesome.
- If you're looking for
more honest and thoughtful
conversations about tech,
instead of nonstop yelling.
Check out our tech playlist.
And if you wanna
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics.
Check out our full
episode playlists.
They're right over here.
And to get notified
of all future videos.
Be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.